look at this story this is from
timcast.com maryland department of
education will require pre-k students to
learn about gender identity and
expression the state's health curriculum
curriculum aims to examine how racism
impacts sexual identity by middle school
i want to bring this away how racism
impacts
gender identity by middle school but so
hold on i got it i got i got a bone to
pick with this your timcast.com is it a
four foot long bone will require
when you actually pull up the document
it actually has on it uh
pre-kindergarten through high school
first july 2020 to june 2021 it sounds
like they're already doing it and now i
have questions about the website but the
website is is linked through the
maryland.gov portal so this is coming
out of maryland's public school website
this document talking about
pre-kindergarten through high school and
what they're going to be teaching these
kids
i don't think that it's in it it's a
it's planned opposition to what's
happening in florida i think what what
florida is is in effect of opposition to
what they've already been doing yeah and
it was already happening in florida too
and this is uh by the way talking about
the history of things i mean
comprehensive sex education
that started with with alfred kinsey was
another pedophile and and uh and and
expressly wanted to and believe wanted
to sexualize children believe that
children are sexual literally from birth
and it's a whole story there's totally
horrifying but comprehensive
comprehensive sex education goes back to
him it starts there and so it is a from
the beginning an effort to sexualize
children to sexualize them also kind of
based in this kind of circular way on
the idea that children are already
sexual from birth
and the thing about that that's so
insidious because we see that oh they're
teaching this stuff to preschoolers we
find it so shocking and it is
i mean it's horrifying but it's actually
not
surprising because well of course they
want to get to the kids that young
because when you're that when you're
four years old i mean these are the kids
who believe you know in santa claus they
like they think that spider-man is real
so
at that age psychologically they cannot
distinguish they actually cannot
distinguish between between reality and
fantasy if you go to a four-year-old
and you say to the four-year-old
superman doesn't exist they won't even
know what you mean by that doesn't mean
anything doesn't exist what do you mean
i can see him on tv i know he exists and
so that's
the left's ideas about especially about
gender are so
ridiculous and insane that they have to
get to the kids that young
at an age where they where they don't
have the mental capacity to see it for
the absurdity that it is well and if you
can indoctrinate them that young then
you get them you know potentially for
life what's funny to me is uh that's
what i was told growing up about
christianity
was that the church goes it goes tries
to get the kids so that they grow up
indoctrinated in the church and dogma
and things like that and now we're
i gotta say it is fascinating to see
that when it comes to critical race
theory gender ideology and the general
world cult it seems that they're doing a
lot of what the left claimed the right
did a long time ago like they're they're
arguing the other side does it but
they're doing it and the difference is
so yeah you hear that argument about
that that's what that's what what
religions do and the left makes that
argument it's actually interesting
because what they're essentially
admitting is that gender ideology is a
religion and so that part i agree with
them at least we have it in the right
category it's actually a religious point
of view but the difference is that um
with christianity
you you can ask really difficult
questions
and in fact for most christians who are
informed like they want to have that
conversation let's talk about it why do
i believe in the bible why do i believe
in god let's have the conversation it's
it's great um with gender ideology
though this is why they have to get to
the kids very young
it collapses under the slightest
scrutiny they cannot answer like any
questions about it
ask them to find their terms they can't
do it and so that's well that's why they
resort to insults